ومن خلصن ينضم الينا من هناك مراسل
الجزيره صهيب العصا صهيب الوضع في خصم كما
يعني تتابعه الان صف لنا المشهد وهذا تجمع
لهؤلاء السكان المدينه اللي خارج ربما
ابتهاجا بسيطره او يعوده سيطره اوكرانيا
عليها ماذا عن زياره زي الاسكي ايضا
[موسيقى]
صحيح عبد الصمد
وانت في الطريق الى خير يمكن مشاهده الناس
الذين ينتظرون في القرى على بوابات هذه
المدينه التي استعادت القوات الاوكرانيا
سيطره عليها خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
بعد سبعه شهور المتواصله من السيطره
الروسيه على هذه المدينه مدينه خيرسون
كانت تحت سيطره القوات الروسيه وسقطت
بيدها القوه الروسيه كاول مقاطعه تسقط
بالكامل بيدي القوه همم الروسيه منذ بدايه
هذه الحرب والرئيس الاوكراني اليوم كان
هنا قبل اقل من نصف ساعه قبل اقل من ساعه
حقيقه كان هنا في زياره سريعه همم توقف
لرفع العالم الاوكراني في هذه الساحه
والقى كلمه للصحفيين ومن ثم ادى تحيه
لهؤلاء المتجمرين هنا طبعا زياره
لمدينه غير سوريا يعكس اهميتها لم ااه
يتحرك بعيدا عن كيف همم الا في بس بعد
قليله وقليل الغايه منها ايزيوم مثلا في
جنوبيه اخر كيب عندما تم اكتشافه الحديث
عن مقابر جماعيه تركتها القوات الروسيه
هناك وفق ما تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه وهذه
هذه الزياره التي ياتي فيها زنسكي الى
مدينه خيبسون تعكس اهميه هذه المقاطعه
القوات الاوكرانيه تقول الان انها استعاده
السيطره على حوالي 30% من مساحه مقاطعه
غير سور الاهم من كل ذلك الناس استعاده
السيطره على وسط مدينه خيرسون على قلب
مدينه خيسون والقوات الروسيه الان غيرت
همم العاصمه الاداريه لمقاطعه خيصون لتكون
في
اقصى جنوب
شرقي مقاطعه خرسانه التي تبعد منها حوالين
200 همم كيلو متر تقريبا نستمع الى اصوات
انفجارات في السماء ولكن لا نعرف ان كانت
هذه همم مضادات الصواريخ او انها كانت
اصوات القصف التي تقوم بها القوات
الاوكرانيه باتجاه القوات الروسيه طبعا
نحن نعلم ان القوات الروسيه لا تبعد من
هنا الا وضعت كيلو مترات حيث تقع مدينه
خيرسون على نهر دنيبرو والنهار الان هو
الخط الفاصل بين القوات الروسيه والقوات
الاوكرانيه وبالتالي القوات الاوكرانيه
تقول انها ستواصل القتال لتتقدم نحو الضفه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه من مقاطعه كرشون هل هذا
ممكن هذا سؤال كبير لان هناك جسرين مهمين
تم تدميرهما جسر
انترنتسكي تم تدميره وبالتالي الطريق
مقطوعه بين ضفتين همم النهر في غير سون
هذا يضع رقيقه قويه جدا امام القوات
الاوكراني اذا محاولت التقدم اكثر واكثر
اليوم مع رفع العلم الاوكراني في وسط
مدينه
سيرسون لاول مره منذ سبعه شهور تبرز هناك
تحديات مهمه في توفير الماء والكهرباء
والاتصالات والانترنت للسكان هنا تحدثنا
مع عدد كبير من السكان الذين كانوا
يتحدثون عن اوضاع سوريه للغايه عاشوها
خلال الشهور السبعه الماضيه تحت ظل
ترى الروسيه الحديث ايضا عن الاستفتاء
الذي يسخر منه الناس هنا ويقولون ان
القوات الروسيه حاولت فرض عمليه استفتاء
على السكان المحليين لاظهار عمليه
الانفصال همم خرسون عن اوكرانيا وكانها
محاوله شعبيه ولكن يقولون بان هذه
المحاوله فشلت وان القوات الروسيه الان
فاتت خارج هذه المدينه وستكون قريبا خارج
هذه المقاطعه كما يقول الاوكراني نحن
نشاهد الاعداد الكبيره من الناس التي
تحتجه هنا في وسط على العاصمه غير سوريا
لاول مره كانوا يتحدثون عن اوضاع جدا
ماسونيه عن صعوبه بالغه في الحركه عن
مراقبه لكل شيء كما يقولون هنا كانت
القوات الروسيه تقوم بها
وكان الظروف سيئه للغايه كما يقولون وصول
الرئيس الانجليز كل يوم والرسائل التي
ارسلها بان الخطه التي فعلتها القوات
الاوكرانيه الخطه الدفاعيه لاستعاده
السيطره اخرصون اتت اكلها ونجحت حتى هذه
اللحظه في استعاده السيطره على هذه
المساحه الخطه ما زالت مستمره والقوات
الاوك الناس تواصل تقدمها كان يتحدث عن
جرائم حرب كما يصفها و- اا ارتكبتها
القوات الروسيه في خرسون وادى تحيه
العسكريه للعلم وايضا حيا الناس
المتواجدين هنا وقال ان احتشاد الناس هنا
في هذه الساحه هو الاعتراف الطبيعه
والاستفتاء الطبيعي لما ستكون عليه خرسون
لمكانه عليه بالمستقبل انها ستبقى ارض
اوكرانيه وان كل الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها
القوات روسيه في الجنوب والجنوب الشرقي من
البلاد ستعود للسيطره الاوكرانيه وتعبير
الرئيس الاوكراني
عبد الصمد شكرا